どうも
（ワタナベマホトです？）
シュシュシュ(マホト風)
というわけで(？)皆さん、私はじめしゃちょー
今年一年…
お肉が食えません
肉が食べたいです........
焼き肉食べたい........
チャー↑シュー入りのラーメンが食べたい........
あぶりカルビ寿司食べたい........
ハンバーグ食べたい........
ビックマック食べたい........
トニカク＃＄％＆＆％＄食べたーーーい(´;ω;｀)
うぅぅぅぅ（本気で泣いているはじめ）
そんな僕に…
そんな僕に(大事なことなので二回言いました)
奇跡のような商品が舞い降りました
こちら(イケボ)
っはい！
まるナゲ
もうぱっと見ナゲットなんすけどぉ(？)
これ実は大豆ミートで作った！
ま　る　で　ナ　ゲ　っ　ト　(？)です
あー　なんだ
くそつまんねー
まさに…
まさに俺のための商品じゃねーかー
作ってくれた人、ありがとうございます！
ヤバい、俺を狙った商品かもしれない((((；ﾟДﾟ))))ｶﾞｸｶﾞｸﾌﾞﾙﾌﾞﾙ
すごくないスカ？これ、
よーするにナゲットなんですよ
食感も味もナゲットなんです
けども！
大豆ミートと呼ばれる、
つまりこれお肉は使われてないんですけども、
ナゲットらしいです
ちなみに、コンビニに売ってました
これだったらもうお肉食い放題じゃん！
って話になるんですけど
勝ち確やん！！シャーー！
というわけで、ちょっと食べてみましょう
これもしお肉の味だとすると
僕はもう３ヶ月ぶりにお肉の味を味わうわけです
えーでもこれ。。えーーー。。。
お肉じゃないもんね！お肉じゃないんで、僕は大丈夫です
変な罪悪感が生まれてきてますが
ほい！
お～ほほぉ
ナゲットっていうか唐揚げっぽいっすね
見た目はホントちょっと湿ったナゲット。。？
唐揚げ？みたいな感じでございます
結構小さめですね
大丈夫！🍖入ってないです！です！！
では疑似的にお肉３ヶ月ぶりにたべます
いただきます
食べてびっくりするはじめ
ナゲットだー(確信)
えっすげー　マジでこれナゲットじゃん
えっすげー
え、分かんない。。ナゲットとしか思えない
はい、というわけでこういうマルナゲって言うですね
もう疑似的ニセお肉があるんですけど
今回このナゲットを使って
ドッキリを仕掛けたいと思います
いや～みなさん！よく考えて見て下さい。
僕はお肉を禁止している...ちなみに本気でやってます
裏でも食べてないんですけども
僕の周りの人は僕が裏でも食べてない事を、全部知っているわけです
後輩が部屋に入ってきて
お肉絶対食べないマンの僕が
その禁忌（きんき）をおかして、こっそりナゲットを食ってたら
どう思う？
そしてどう反応するのか？
も、僕は純粋に気になっております
では早速、仕込んでいきましょう
ちなみに今ターゲットは上にいるんで、静かに行きましょう
この中にいかにも大き目でお肉っぽいマルナゲを
僕がおいしそうにパクパク食べてます
周りから見ると
そんな僕が、、たまたま入ってきた後輩が見て
まず何を思って何を話すのか
まぁまぁ、小さめの唐揚げには見えますね
こんな感じでいかがでしょうか？
はい、というわけで早速仕掛ける部屋に行って
お肉を食べていきましょう
ではいこう！👿
た：え、なあに？
は：違う違う　　た：なあに？
た：マジで怖い
た：ん”ん”ん”！！
た：あ”－－
た：や！ダメじゃん！！
は：いや、ちょっとしか食ってないでも
た：いや～いやいやいやいや
た：まって
た：いや！肉じゃん！
た：何やってんすか！ホントに、、
た：飲んでる？え？口は？
た：ねぇぇぇ
た：いや、マジで食ってるじゃないっすか！
た：え？マジっすか？
は：そんな顔で見ないで。。
た：いや、別に別にいいですけど、、
た：良かったんですか？食べちゃって。。
は：いや、魔が差したホントに
は：え、でも
エンディング♪
ご視聴ありがとうございました
でもまだ続きがあるよ〜
た;　えっ　でも肉じゃん
は;　たなっちこれは…
肉では…
ございません！
は：中身を大き目のやつをピックアップして
は：たなっちに、肉禁止なのに肉食うドッキリっていう...
は：ほら
た：あ、ほんとだ(^-^)
た：ほんとだ☺やられた～☺
た：マジであせった～でも